I'm opening the executive session on
House Bill 1050 and we're just going to
um recess it for a couple minutes until
the rest of the members get once we
start up
just recessing it for a
minute until we get everybody in
here everyone who's here we're we're
just waiting for a couple amendments
before we start the
day
M uh please rise and join me for the
Pledge of
Allegiance I pled Al to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
repblic for stands one nation God
indivisible with Li and jce for
all
everyone would please excuse the delay
we had a a member sick this morning so
we had to kind of re everything we were
doing so with that I am opening the
public hearing excuse me the executive
session on House Bill 1050 and I
recognize representative Muse to make a
motion thank you Mr chair I recommend um
HB 1050 ought to pass can I have a
second
seconded motion made by representative
Muse OTP seconded by representative
Murray representative would you like to
speak to your motion uh yes um briefly
in most parts of the country including
New Hampshire uh there is no ability uh
to voluntarily add yourself to the
federal firearms background check system
what this bill would do is change that
by establishing uh voluntary uh do not
sell list uh in the state of New
Hampshire for people who wish to
volunteer L wave their firearms rights
um I think we heard uh uh some emotional
and and poignant testimony uh during the
public hearing for this bill um I also
don't think we heard uh any uh any
serious uh objections to this uh from a
Libertarian standpoint this is
essentially what this bill uh would do
is the most Libertarian thing ever um it
basically gives people control over
their own destiny uh it lets them make
the choice uh and this is vitally
important uh for people uh who suffer
from episodic mental illness uh around
uh things like severe depression uh
bipolar uh uh bipolar illnesses and
things of that nature who may be totally
in control of themselves at one point um
and then not so much uh at a at a
different point in time what what this
essentially allows them to do is to take
the most lethal potential form of
suicide off the table but only for
themselves uh and what it also allows
them to do at a point where they would
they feel better would they feel more
confident in their abilities where they
feel like their um their mental health
has improved significantly they can get
themselves off the list um so uh bottom
line uh this is a bill that actually um
uh increases uh freedom for some people
and the ability to make uh a choice that
they that they want to make on a
voluntary basis so I would urge you to
uh uh to pass it thank
you thank you representative Murray
would you like to speak to your
second um I would just affirm what
representative Muse said and that if
people are looking for a way to protect
themselves from themselves we should
give them the ability to do so thank you
and I'll start discussion by saying that
I I think I can speak for the minority
present today that that first blush this
seemed like a a good bill to me it
seemed um it seemed to make
sense but during the testimony um I
particularly was taken aback by the um
testimony from the New Hampshire Medical
Association when they testified that
they liked it because it helped um their
their to further the end that they
testified was their goal was to um
obtain lists of people that own firearms
and I found that rather
disturbing um and I also some of the
testimony we heard was concerning with
regard to potential to influence people
to put their names on this list um when
that may may not necessarily be what
they want I realized that the bill has
some guard rails against that but they
would be probably
um um very difficult to enforce if
someone's doctor said you need to put
your name on this list if you want to be
continued to be treated by me or things
of that nature so um for that reason I
think that we would not support it um
further
discussion representa Stone thank you Mr
chairman and uh I'd like to say that
this bill uh is a red flag bill it also
uh creates a penalty for an individual
who is voluntarily doing something which
is kind of uh disturbing in itself in
the language of the bill uh furthermore
I I really think it uh creating a
registry even voluntarily is a slippery
slope when providing your personal
information to any government entity and
it may uh have unnecessary consequences
in the future if that information
happens to be retained and there is no
statutory time frames of which requires
an individual to submit to have their
name off the list of which that would
occur those are some of the points that
I just uh picked up out of it that are
most concerning to
me thank you further
discussion represent wheeler thank you
Mr
chairman I I appreciate your concerns
and the concerns brought by Mr Stone and
I Shar the concern about coercion I I
was worried about that when I heard that
in the public public hearing as well but
I do think that representative Muse has
crafted uh legislation which was
thoughtfully put through with the right
guard rails in place and and I think
that um you know in my reading about uh
this program as it's been implemented in
Utah and Virginia and Washington um and
the program as it's being proposed in
other states it seems to be working and
it seems to be uh working in an
efficient way where people aren't being
coursed onto the list and and where uh
this information is being kept private
from from people who might uh use it for
malicious means and it is being used to
to help people
from going out and harming themselves
when they know that when they the
individual know that they shouldn't uh
have a weapon so uh I share your
hesitations Mr chairman um as you know I
have different opinions than the the
rest of my team on this but I also I
think that this is uh a bill that that's
worth supporting and I and I'll be
voting uh for a to pass on this
legislation thank you further
discussion see none oh representative
site my objection is that we it's not I
don't know that the bill is necessary
and may this may not be a substance
objection but I just hate to see the
body of law get expanded by another a
few pages it's already
enormous uh thank you all righty um with
that I'd ask the clerk to call the role
the motion on the floor is ought to
pass Vice chair roads no representative
Pratt no representative scitec yes
representative
pu no Representative jandrin no
representative Manion no representative
Reed no represent representative Stone
no representative Harriet goth yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balon yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Sue Newman yes representative wheeler
yay chairman Roy chair votes no um
118 motion carries 118 ought to pass um
representative Muse I I'll need uh your
report uh before you leave today please
um who's going to and Minority Report
representative Stone saying I need to
report
today and with that I Clos the executive
session on House Bill
1050 and I opened the executive session
on House Bill
and we'll be making a motion
representative Newman I recognize you
for a motion make the motion to itl I
don't believe this bill is necessary I
think that Merchants should label things
any way they want to label them I also
think that the penalty is excessive
$10,000 for reach occurrence I don't
know whether that's each occurrence on
the bill or whatever it is I just think
that this bill is
unnecessary
second second seconded by representative
here at gath right
would you like to speak to your
motion yeah I guess he kind of did
didn't he would you like to speak to
your
second discussion representative
jaman thank you Mr chairman uh it's
unfortunate that the uh credit card
companies and the bankers Association
sat with me crafted a Amendment to the
bill that strikes the
$110,000 um and makes the person liable
for that uh any penalty would be the
credit card uh transaction company and
not the credit card companies or the
banks um and if you don't think this
bill is necessary I will point to the
state of California where this morning
CBS News reported that they will be
using
um fire and purchasing codes and that
financial institutions are required by
State LA in California
to share that information with the state
police so if you don't think this is uh
necessary in a Live Free Die Live Free
or Die State I think you're sadly
mistaken thank you I would um I'd add to
that that I would ask the members to
think what if it wasn't about Firearms
what if it was um a red State and the
governor was getting information from a
company that was tracking um for example
purchases made by by lgbtq people or
trans people um to to find out who was
getting operations and contrary to what
they wanted or any number of things the
government using private companies to
further its ends is is nefarious it's a
horrible practice to start and I think
that we need to keep a very very close
eye on that because the Big Brother
state is here and when you can't make a
purchase with without the government
knowing it and keeping track of it that
that's problematic as you can see what
has happened here in our state with our
um medical marijuana
programs they're all Cash and Carry
because um the government's keeping an
eye and will shut down any bank that
processes any of that so it's it's a
like I said it's a very slippery slope
when the government's Mand watching what
we're
buying representative Stone thank you Mr
chair in regards to this bill if you
believe that an individual's right to
privacy outweighs anyone else's rights
when it comes to tracking your
information even your buying habits you
would support having this bill ought to
pass in addition uh I think the chairman
hit it right on the head is where do we
go if it's just gun rights is it going
to be transgenders is it going to be
other issues that come up and evolve I
think this is a problematic bill and I
think it uh has issues where we need our
privacy protected if we look at the New
Hampshire Constitution specifically
section to article B government
intrusion is there for a reason and
again I would urge everybody to uh vote
ought to pass on this bill and not
itl just to clarify you weren't saying
the Bill's problematic but the
Situation's problematic the situation is
highly problematic where you're tracking
individual's rights to what they
purchase and the government has no right
to know what you're buying and and
further your point we just not just we
but the people of the state just adopted
a constitutional amend
to be have privacy in their effects and
their information from the government
and the government is using a back door
to get it around that Amendment
represent wheeler thank you Mr chairman
I agree with what you said I don't think
it is a uh far-fetched idea nor is it
far-fetched to say that the government
right now has
become uh excessive in how much it is
willing to to trample on people's
privacy rights uh we saw from the
Wikileaks documents and Edward Snowden
and other Chelsea Manning and other
whistleblowers that have come out to
discuss some of the things that the
military and intelligence agencies have
done when it comes to
extrajudicial uh surveillance on the
American public and I'm very concerned
it's not a a q andon conspiracy at all
to say that the government is moving
forward on this it's a Well documented
and established fact and as I think you
articulated very well Mr chairman this
could be used you know take guns away it
could be used for any number of things
tracking people's behavior and when we
live in a state in which we have passed
a constitutional amendment affirming
people's right to privacy and when we
say that people are individuals and have
their individual right
to have their uh transactions private
then I I think that this is a
legislation worth supporting I think
representative jamron has put in a lot
of diligent work working with people who
are going to be affected by this and and
I I uh uh will be voting against the itl
motion uh in hopes that we can bring
forward the amendment that he has
brought forward and and uh that another
motion can be
made thank you for the
discussion represent
use so basically what these codes would
do would be to allow the banks and the
credit card companies to to basically
support uh suspicious and potentially
illegal activity uh so a lot of credit
cards have uh have pretty high limits um
one of the things that might flag uh the
interest of of uh of the company might
be a purchase of let's say
$20,000 uh worth of firearms and
ammunition all made at the same time um
I think that there's uh one of the
things I think we also need to recognize
is that um uh while there have been
states that have pass laws that um uh
that would not allow that would
essentially disallow credit card
companies and Banks from gathering this
information um the credit card companies
themselves have uh
suspended uh there have have essentially
um suspended this policy uh the policy
right now is under review uh there's
also an effort uh at the national level
uh to take a look at this and to put
additional guard rails around the
practice one of the things I will say
that that's also danger is creating a a
patchwork of different state laws so New
Hampshire does it one way Virginia does
it slightly differently California does
something completely different what it
does is it is it adds significantly to
uh you know to the cost uh for the you
know for uh for some of these companies
um you know in terms of um you know
whether or not uh something like this is
you know is is good public policy um I
don't think there's really any evidence
that any of this information would
actually be used to put together any
kind of registry or anything like that
um I mean essentially it's in in in a
lot of ways it's not very different uh
from what social media companies do when
they see a uh uh like a
particularly um
uh uh you know I guess a particularly
crazy post uh from from an individual
that might indicate what an that that
individual is doing harm um lawn uh
social media companies uh are you know
will cooperate with law enforcement and
situations like that um I'm not I'm not
seeing uh the potential uh uh for uh the
kind of abuse that would lead you to
think that law-abiding gun owners are
going to be targeted uh for simply
purchasing another box of ammunition uh
for their hand gun uh purchasing another
rifle for hunting I I don't see a
situation like that um and I think one
of the things that we need to do is try
as best we can to actually make laws
that respond to actual problems uh and I
don't think this is an actual problem
thank
you thank you um I I found it
interesting you said that it was a law
that might be used to track illegal
activity and then you said such as
perhaps purchasing 20 $1,000 worth of
firearms or ammunition one rifle can
cost
$20,000 and that's highly legal and it's
frankly none of the government's
business um or if I bought 10 of those
until it's illegal it's my it's my right
and I don't think that the government
should be able to track my rights
representative Stone thank you Mr chair
I'd like to point out that uh anybody
that holds a credit card has the option
much like in 1050 of voluntarily setting
limits to set to be flagged if your
credit card is being used in excess of
either 5 three or whatever denomination
you want to set in addition uh we
already have laws in effect that if uh
firearm purchases are very legal such as
straw purchases they're address both at
the federal level which has a high
degree of
uh imprisonment and high fines attached
to it uh I just I think this is an
invasion of privacy and I know in the
past I've worked with entities in my
employment post 911 where a lot of
information was gained through
financials whether it' be bill paying or
it be uh other purchases that you could
get subpoenaed records on to help build
a case if you so desired to so there are
avenues that have been in existence of
tracking information and this just adds
to it and codifies it where we're
justifying tracking people's individual
rights and privacy is
violated members of the committee before
representative I'm sorry before chairman
Roy calls on the next person if you
could all please silence your phones
your computers whatever you have open
we're we're hearing a lot of dinging and
and it's it's it's quite disrespectful
so please turn your your your ringers
your volumes off thank
you representative Stone um you have a
huh
oh jam I'm sorry representative jamron
you um you had mentioned what your
amendment was going to
do if it did it did it um address any of
the concerns we've
heard uh actually uh when representative
Newman had made his motion he had
mentioned a $10,000 fine uh the
amendment strikes that $10,000 fine and
leaves the Civil penalty up to the uh
Court of appropriate jurisdiction to
determine that any other changes to the
bill other than that uh it changed so
that the um person that would be liable
for prosecution or this is not the
issuer of the card but the card
processing Network that's the two
changes thank you um representative
Balden um I was just curious if the
sponsor or anyone on the committee could
speak to how this would impact
preventing acts of
[Music]
terrorism
um I I don't understand the question
maybe you could clarify it how how would
it How would how would it be involved in
Act of
terrorism terrorists use weapons and if
they purchase them so on a credit
card then law enforcement might be aware
I guess that question presupposes that
everyone who buys a firearm should be
screened for
terrorism what was there a threshold
that that you think that they should be
able to see I don't know I'm not I'm not
in the FBI but I wonder if it would make
it difficult for them to if this isn't
if this coding isn't a tool in their
toolbx I I would suggest that uh I will
a second represent Pro um I would
suggest that the government already
knows via um when a firearm is
purchased um from an FFL
dealer they have a track of every weapon
they sell so they know that these
weapons are being sold and reports are
made to the um to the federal government
from the FFL dealer of their sales so
and the F ATF can walk in any time and
see the list of all the sales they made
and they have to be provided so there's
already a the ability to to see it but
they have to have a they have to have a
reasonable cause to think there's a
crime they can't just screen everybody
and say well that one might be criminal
or that one might be criminal
representative PR did you want to add to
that well I would like to say
that I don't know any terrorist or
criminal for the most part that uses a
credit card to buy their weapons they're
usually Black Market weapons that have
been stolen
already um so they can't be traced back
to that
so they're not using credit
cards and as I continue on this usually
most transactions over $10,000
automatically get flagged to the
government so if you're spending
$220,000 on anything it gets flagged or
$10,000 And1 or actually
10,000
um and to representative M uh social
media yeah they may point it out to the
government but it's that post is already
in the public so you're not reaching
into their their secret private stuff
it's they already put it out there and
somebody just says hey did you see this
so I think that's a little bit different
than me using my credit card and my
company telling the government
everything that I'm
buying good points um who's
left represent
Pratt I was oh I was going to speak to
an earlier statement about list um if
you're put on a list if you use your
credit card to buy marijuana legally in
New Hampshire that'll put you that could
possibly put you on a list uh right now
federally it's against the law now
you're on a list so just to keep you in
mind as the list start getting built by
what you buy on a credit card it can be
used for
everything I would um I believe you
can't use a credit card in New Hampshire
can you no but I think in Massachusetts
you might be able to at the dis at their
open no as far as I know it's a Cash and
Carry business because of the federal
government um representive
Jamber thank you Mr chairman uh I did
want to point out I did mention
California this morning um so I'll
clarify what I meant by that um the
reason that the credit card companies
paused this policy uh when it was
announced in
2022 um there was such push back and
several States passed laws outlawing it
much like this bill would do um and
those was passed and were signed into
law those seven states are the states
that stopped the credit cards from uh
companies from doing this that's why the
policy was suspended so that they would
have time to either work through the
federal government to make it a federal
uh mandate or uh to prohibit it
throughout the states um there is a
patchwork now I the the California it's
literally it was on uh on my way here
Sor on CBS Newsfeed California requires
this to be used and they also require
the agencies that use the credit cards
and and make this list to share that
with the Department of Justice in
California um again we live in the live
Frei State not the whatever they call
themselves over there I call them the
Left Coast so I'm I'm trying to be
polite about it but the reason that it
was suspend
is because several States voted to
prohibit the use the only state that is
mandated mandated that it be used is
California representative
scitech has anybody noticed when
somebody says I'm not going to repeat
previous arguments then they go and
repeat all those previous arguments well
I'm not going to do that the obvious
thing that we've I've not ever heard it
mentioned in the entire discussion you
take take your card go down get cash and
go back and buy it on a cash basis
what's is any nobody's even mentioned
that as far as I know see I would I'd
happy to respond to that I've bought
numerous firearms and I buy them online
um and they don't take cash
unfortunately uh when you do that you
give them your credit card they take the
firearm you purchase they send it to an
FFL in your state you go to the state
FFL they do the background check and
then they give you the firearm there's
no way to give them cash so that would
eliminate that um representative
Balon going back to the earlier topic of
terrorism it's my understanding that the
9911 hijackers did use credit cards in
part to fund their activities and it
this does seem like it could create some
problems for federal law enforcement to
be able to prevent
terrorist
Behavior yeah they they um I think they
used the credit cards to buy plane
tickets and perhaps box cutters but they
didn't use Firearms represent wheeler
thank you Mr chairman I would also just
like to say um because profiling has
brought up so much in this committee
that I would caution us to use the
arguments about terrorism just because
anybody can be a terrorist as we've seen
in the mass shootings and what we've
seen recently any anybody could be a
terrorist you could look like anything
and act like anything and I think as you
said it gets into dangerous territory
where if we start discussing things like
that as is being discussed in the NSA
and other domestic intelligence agencies
then we start getting into a situation
where we're screening every gun owner
who wants to purchase a gun for
terrorism and that gets into privacy
concerns as well representative Stone
thank you and to respond to
representative scitec most uh your too
popular day for gun buying is usually
weekends and ATMs limit the amount of
cash you can get out of an ATM so $500
is not a big threshold for a new firearm
today if you haven't bought one recently
maybe you could get a high
point which which reviews are actually
pretty good on high points um they are
oddl looking Firearms represent Murray
thank you Mr chair um yeah this
discussion is enlightened me a little
bit and I think um I entered this
understanding that the data wasn't going
anywhere and we've heard differently um
based on this conversation I do want to
say that um lgbtq issues have been named
a couple times and um from my
understanding many of the people in this
committee voted against a bill that we
had before us on the floor to protect
people who come here to the state to get
lgbtq surgeries and I believe that um
from getting subpoena from other states
that they come from um that have made
laws against those surgeries and and so
I think I would just ask like if I join
you in this that you be consistent in
that logic and um protect people trans
people in the future who are getting
persecuted for having surgeries and that
kind of uh uh those kind of expenses
being tracked by the government I would
happily sign as a co-art today about
anyone getting information about
purchases used for lgbtq or or frankly
abortion or anything
it's we can debate policy all day long
but when we let the government get into
um taking over that for us we can no
longer debate that policy because it's
set for us by mandate um represent
Balden are we going to terrorist
again I'm pretty sure you could take
more than $500 out of an ATM I've done
that recently but if we're all in
agreement on the things that we don't
want um tracked in these purchases can
we pause amend the bill to include l
related to abortion and LGBT issues and
then pass the
bill um it's not your main I believe it
is we'd have to get a ruling but um it's
an early bill so we got to take care of
it today um I am going to call a um I am
going to call a um brief re recess
because somebody wanted to caucus um yes
and uh we'll take this up again in a
couple
minutes
okay I'm reopening the executive session
on House Bill
1186 and when last we
spoke um there was some discussion
about moving forward um I was did anyone
want to add anything
else okay um the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate I believe and
um I'd ask the court to call the role
Vice chair RADS no representative Pratt
no representative scitec representative
pu no Representative janen no
representative Manion no representative
Reed no representative Stone no
representative gther yes representative
Muse yes representative Balon yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes no
representative Newell no representative
Su
Newman yes representative wheeler n
chairman Roy chair votes no um 712 7 12
the motion fails would anyone like to
make a new motion Mr chairman yes and
make a motion V to pass with Amendment a
second second seconded by representative
Stone um this would be a motion to adopt
an amendment what's the amendment number
Mr chairman the amendment number is 202
24-6 4H would you like to speak to your
motion absolutely the amendment that you
received a copy of this morning uh was
have the request of the New Hampshire
Bankers Association and the uh folks
that represent the credit card companies
uh to the legislature um they came to me
I believe it was Friday with a bunch of
textual uh changes that they wanted that
they wanted to work with and what we've
done is under the Farms code we've
changed it to category 5723 which is
what the international organization or
standardization came up with uh and we
also made the issue
of uh penalty for the payment card
Network it's not specifically a credit
card or the banks that are doing this
it's the the transmitter of the
transaction um and the second change
that this would make is under the
enforcement um it would uh place it
before a court of um jurisdiction that
has jurisdiction over it that they can
seek an injunction and they may also
recover a civil penalty at the
discretion of the court so there's no uh
blank
$10,000 fine um or penalty I'm sorry
it's not a fine it be a penalty so those
are the two changes that are in this
year uh you'll notice that the change
from the original Bill to this one adds
the payment card Network as a chapter so
that it can be utilized further in the
uh section thank you repres Stone would
you like to speak to you a second Mr
chair I'd like to add that I think these
uh changes to the original Amendment
is actually something that's going to be
beneficial and I can support
fully thank you um I'll start discussion
by asking a question when you talk about
processor you're talking about um
companies like for example square or uh
some kind of a merchant processing
system where they actually are a go
between between the retailer and the um
the bank is that correct yes Mr chairman
the if you go into a Walmart today um
the credit card terminal that's there is
actually using the network and there's I
believe seven or eight different ones
Nationwide um and it could be any of
those those are actually the companies
that assign the uh commercial code for
that terminal so yes thank you um and
one last
question you spoke to I believe the
company was American Express um were
they um against this spill or were they
happy to comply once you made the
changes Mr chairman they took no
position in the bill they just requested
that the language be changed to be a
little bit more succinct thank you
further discussion on the
amendment seeing none of ask CL oh sorry
go ahead representative Murphy sorry
thank you um I my question is whether or
not the fiscal note that attached to the
original Bill still applies that it said
that methodology requires the Attorney
General to conduct investigations and
the estimated cost for the two positions
is about $90,000 per year is that is
that still applicable or does the
amendment change that representative I
would actually um counter with the fact
that that representative Muse said uh
right now they've suspended the use of
this code Nationwide with the exception
of California they're required it by
under statute and the reason they did
that is because the several States had
made it illegal because it has been um
paused if we come in with this bill and
it passes and is signed into law the the
credit card companies and the
transmitters have no intention of
utilizing that code in the state of New
Hampshire so the $90,000 that was quoted
in the fiscal note we don't anticipate
that there's going to be any expense
because they will voluntarily comply
with that and that was the consensus I
got from them this morning when I spoke
to him in the hall thank you so to be
clear the cost would be zero as long as
the credit card processors comply with
the
law that's correct and they they have
indicated they voluntarily will will be
uh adhering to the law and and should
they not um does this not allow for them
to be assessed a civil penalty that
could be used to reimburse the Attorney
General's office for their expenses
specifically yes um if you look
at um in the amendment line 36 the
Attorney General May recover reasonable
attorney fees and other reasonable
expenses incurred in the investigation
so that $90,000
effectively would go away yes thank you
further discussion on the
amendment seeing none that ask cler call
the role the motion is um to adopt the
amendment Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec representative pu yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
gather yes
representative M yes representative
Bolton yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Su Newman yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 19 Z 19
zen0 the amendment number 0604 H is
officially adopted can I get another
motion repres representative Jam yes I
move ought to pass as amended second
seconded by representative Stone would
you like to speak to your um motion
representative jamron Mr chairman I
think we've covered the subject matter
and thank you very much for the
opportunity repr Stone would you like to
speak to your second Mr chairman I
concur that we've had a lengthy
discussion I'm all
set agreed I I don't think anything's
change so unless someone wants to add
something further that we haven't
already discussed representative
Newman I voted for the amendment because
it makes this bill a better bill I still
think it's a bad Bill I think it's
unnecessary I think that we're involving
the Attorney General to look after
people that are just designating
merchandise is actually what was sold
and that there's no need to it this
doesn't mandate anything at all it just
does not prohibit them from doing what
they feel they ought to be doing I don't
know maybe it has to do with merchandise
uh restocking or whatever but I think
that the Mandate is a really mandate
that they can't do what they want to do
so I'm going to vote against this
bill I would um I would respond by
saying it's a mandate that they don't
share my private transactions with the
government and that's what the Mandate
is represent Stone thank you Mr chair
I'd like to point out that uh we're
interacting with processing companies
they hire pretty highend attorneys that
help uh keep their their funds where
they belong in the profit margins and
once a state would make a policy like
this they will adhere to it so that they
do not pay out additional funds to
anyone that they don't need
to with that I ask the clerk to call the
role motion of floor is ought to pass as
amended Vice chair
roads representative Pratt yes
representative saitec representative pu
yes representative janen I
representative Manion yes representative
Reed representative Stone yes represent
representative GTH representative muse
no representative Balon no
representative Bradley no representative
Murphy no representative Newman no the
clerk votes yes representative Newell
yes representative of
Sunan no representative
wheeler yay chairman Roy chair votes yes
127 127 the motion carries all to pass
is amended um I need the majority and
Minority Report before you leave today
please thank you with that I close the
executive session and I hereby open the
executive
session on bear with me till I find the
right piece of paper house
bill we're going to skip 1330 for a
moment we're waiting on an amendment
we're going to move on to House Bill
1337 and I
recognize
who any representative Bradley to make a
motion thank you um I recommend to itl
HB
1337 I have a second second seconded by
representative Stone would you like to
speak to your motion representative I
would thank you um HB 1337 will put
victims at an increased risk it all also
puts a burden on the victim to prevent
their abuser from accessing deadly
weapons HB 1337 also makes unnecessary
changes to RSA
173-b a statute intentionally written to
establish protection and enshrine best
practices when it comes to responding to
domestic violence in New Hampshire thank
you representative Stone would you like
to speak to a second Mr chair I would I
think uh one 70 excuse me 1337 had good
intentions uh I think there was a lot of
work that needed to be changing in the
bill and I think uh removing anything
from the 173b section of rsas is
problematic and that's why I would be
supporting the
itl thank you further
discussion seeing none i' ask cler to
call the role motion on a floor is
inexpedient to legislate Vice chair
roads yes representative Pratt yes
representative citec yes representative
pu yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative gther yes representative
Muse yes representative bden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Su Newman yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 190 190 the
motion of inexpedient to legislate
carries any objection to consent seeing
none it's going to on to consent
calendar of sen Bradley I need the
report today please with that I close
the executive session I hereby open in
the executive session
on House Bill
1339 I recognize representative Stone to
introduce an
amendment yes
sir this bill
has this bill has actually been amended
in a form that that's extremely
different from uh the original Bill uh
the original Bill uh
uh essentially would have uh e extended
the role of the New Hampshire State
Police in doing Federal in in doing uh
firearms background checks uh to long
guns as well as handguns uh what this
what this bill does is it it essentially
changes the process for returning of
firearms after restraining orders um my
issue is not necessarily with the
amendment that representative Stone has
created um my issue is more uh one of
process my understanding is that this
issue was brought to the attention of
the chair uh last week one one of the
consequences of doing it this way is uh
because this is the equivalent of a
brand new bill it has never really had a
public hearing uh it's not really
Germain there may have been people who
would have liked to have testified on
this bill one way or the other uh who
were not able to do so because it was
never really identified like that so um
I know that we're in a little bit of a
pickle uh with with early bills but I do
think that this is something that from a
from a process perspective we do need to
pay attention to things like
this thank you representative
representative Stone would you like to
address the gerous issue on this please
I would Mr chairman uh this amendment is
uh under Amendment uh 0
605h and it does it is Germain to The
Heading it puts a lot of the uh
responsibility on the New Hampshire gun
line which is administered by the New
Hampshire Department of Safety which uh
they have significant role in and
therefore I feel that this bill fixes
some issues we've heard with other bills
that were brought before us
previously in addition uh it also
addresses some of the issues that was
identified in 1337 as being problematic
for its uh change in language for
173b this bill was properly noticed as a
subcommittee and the public was noticed
to appr uh to show up and we actually
pretty much had a public hearing where
we heard the concerns of both the New
Hampshire Department of Safety and from
the domestic violence Coalition and I
believe uh Chief Goldstein spoke on
behalf it's either the New Hampshire
Chiefs of Police Association or the New
Hampshire Police Officers Association
and when you had the amendment drafted
did uh OS indicate to you in any way
that this was a non-gain Amendment they
did not thank you um representative Muse
your your objection is noted um and you
are are uh free obviously to um speak to
the the clerk and the speaker after and
if they so rule then um I guess the bill
will go into nowhere land I'm not sure
what happens to it at that point um with
that I in I um introduce your Amendment
please actually you have to need a
second on
it second second of Representative
janen would you like to speak to your
motion yeah I'd like to clarify that uh
this motion uh excuse me this amendment
basically changes the word after
speaking with the Department of Safety
in which they felt that they could work
with the parameters of uh May versus
shell which was the only real change
from the what I referred to as MCU
amendment that was initially put forward
at the subcommittee and I believe the
domestic Coalition was uh had no issues
with the way the bill was written and
basically this bill adds time frames for
the judicial aspect of uh returning your
Firearms does not negate any background
checks but actually sets forth that the
court would have approximately 10
business days to schedule one and it
also get a response from the Nicks line
which is administered by the Department
of Safety Division of State
Police thank you would you like to speak
to your second representative
Jam I concur with his comments and I
defer representative um if you could for
um mine and the rest of the committee's
um education um walk me through what
this actually means mechanically as far
as someone has a an order in their um
weapons are seized Mr chair I'm going to
use the example of a just a restraining
order that it's expired upon expiration
there is no paperwork that's generated
it just gets out of the system it shows
it's expired and it's no longer valid an
individual who's previously prohibited
from purchasing a firearm or possessing
a firearm can actually go as soon as the
order is expired and buy a new firearm
however that individual cannot simply
show up at the police department and say
I'd like my my firearms return to me
that you seized uh they would have to be
doing a motion with the court previously
there was no time frames the court could
determine it on their schedule this
would provide guard Wills of 10 days uh
once the uh order is given the next
background check would be initiated by
the request of the Court it would then
be approved by the judge all parties
obviously would be noticed that have uh
invested into the hearing and at that
point the judge would make a
determination to direct the law
enforcement agency that seized the guns
to return the Firearms basically the
premise is uh the co-sponsor uh
representative Manion brings out if the
orders are are done by a court to take
Firearms then it needs to be an order
given to return the Firearms which gives
most law enforcement agencies a
comfortable feeling knowing that they
have a document they can have that says
I was or we were ordered to return
firearms and put in their file either
electronically or in a hard
copy thank you so basically basically
distilled down what this does is it it
stops the process whereby someone has a
restraining order against them the order
expires they're free to go buy all the
Firearms they wanted to store but in
order to get their own firearms back to
reased they had to go to court and go
through an a process that could cost
them more money in time just to get the
Firearms back this alleviates that Mr
chair it does and another thing this
also does is the state does not want to
be holding on the responsibility of
anyone's property if there's no
legitimate legal reason to do so and
most agencies I spoken to in regards to
this issue are accepting of this because
they want to get these items out of
their evidence rooms as well and if
there's no legal basis for the state to
be holding something they shouldn't be
inuring that liability either and what
what if any push back was there after
you amended it was there any push back
after you had it finally in its final
form I believe all the uh shareholders
that were here during this process were
pretty confident with the language as it
was amended thank you further discussion
oh representative um
rhods thank you Mr chairman if if I may
ask uh a question of Representative
Stone go ahead and could you just um my
my question is is was the coal was the
New Hampshire Coalition were they here
for your subcommittee and if they were
could you just give us uh some feedback
if they spoke to at the bill they were
and I hope I met all their concerns
their biggest concern was the fact of
not having background checks done I
think that was satisfied and I'm not
sure if she's still here or not but she
was here for the subcommittee and their
big concern was making sure that there
was in fact a next background check
conducted before issuing the Firearms
back by the court and as I advised her
as I did many that usually the court of
jurisdiction that has authority over
this is usually the court that issued
the orders for domestic in the case of
173b so they will have the file and in a
course of regular business as we all
know uh most of the communities they
have frequent flyers same individuals
they know who they're dealing with they
also have access to the New Hampshire
Court database whether it be superior
court or it be uh Circuit Court they
have all the information they need it
just gives them a next step to use the
next line to be able to validate there's
not an outside order and the reason for
the changing the word from Shell provide
a response to May is that the state
police felt it was imperative they'd be
able to give a response in the case of
State Massachusetts they reach out to a
Massachusetts court the Massachusetts
court says yeah we'll get right back to
you they never hear from them again
they'd at least be able to produce a
letter and document to have a cover
letter to say look we've done everything
we found no prohibitions but we have no
response from this say hypothetically
the Lynn Massachusetts District Court
they never provideers re response but
from our end we we don't see any reasons
not to return firearms and with regard
to that point if um a court in
Massachusetts had in fact entered a new
restraining order or um a conviction of
some type that would show up in the next
check anyway is that not true yeah the
restraining order would be in next and
spots representative Newman I just have
a question since I I believe this is the
first time we've seen this amendment is
that correct that's a question for the
chair I think other than the
subcommittee yeah that's a full-time the
full committee Ser it yeah and who and
did we get a report from the
subcommittee that's a question for the
chair I believe that um representative
stone is talking about it right now I
mean was there a vote taken or I'm just
wondering if there there was no vote
taken at the subcommittee the the
majority consensus was to return to the
full committee for the executive session
okay and now can I I have a question
absolutely could you just point out
where the change from Sha to May is I
see some Shalla knots in there so I see
a bunch of shs I'm sorry that would be
on line
31 on the first
page be under 30 prohibited from
possessing a firearm within 10 business
days of the Court's request the
department of safety May provide a
proceeded response to the requesting
court so previously it was shell which
as we know shells you will do it versus
May which gives the
option a
followup and so but I do see there are
still several shells in here the court
shall not the court shall not be
required to request conductor receive
the results of background
check draw my question because I want to
read that more
carefully I'm repres Stone there are
there are occasions this bill also
covers uh issues other than 173b 173b
and uh 633 -3 are demestic violence and
stalking uh there nothing prohibits a
police department in other circumstances
such as a uh bail condition ending
that's non-domestic related from
Firearms being returning but it also
seeks out if the individual police
department does not want it to go to uh
you know if they don't don't want to
give the guns up freely they can
actually request a court
action but the protections for for the
domestic Coalition was more geared
towards the 173b protection and the
6333 thank you further
discussion representative Murphy thank
you thank you for taking my question my
question was um on page one line 2829
can you clarify um how it what uh
circumstances would lead a niy check to
come back
inconclusive that would be the examp
example I gave of an out of state court
which refuses to cooperate with New
Hampshire and then New Hampshire has no
uh they can't force Massachusetts to
cooperate and a lot of times uh probably
less than I'd say 3% in the Firearms
industry do you get a uh a nonresponse
back that's been my experience uh I know
that generally you either get a denied
or an approval pretty quick the delay
usually responds for further information
inquiries and this is not 100% you know
you're going to definitely get a
response back especially if you're doing
without a States like bigger States like
Florida even California an inconclusive
is only for saying we're not sure what
the classification of crime in the old
days in the state of New Hampshire uh
domestic violence uh complaints were
actually just a red box that was checked
uh since we've evolved you know
technology has gone further you may
still have some individuals that have to
go pull a manual complaint and see if
that box was checked or we the bed the
complaint to see if it was a domestic
that meets the federal requirements
under their definition of domestic
violence could you clarify though um for
I I have a question so when they do the
ncks check the the instant background
check it it's going to come back with it
doesn't come back with an inconclusive
no there's only three statuses it's
either approved denied or delayed
delayed is usually the one they have to
clarify if there's a uh say like in the
case of a simple assault if you're a
simple assault and it's a straightup
simple assault non-domestic related
that's not a lifetime prohibition if you
have a domestic simple assault and
that's codified and shown to be the case
then you are a prohibited person so but
the delayed doesn't put the onus back on
the local police to follow up with other
courts it's the FBI who has to follow up
to to correct is that correct in in the
case of the gunline if it's a handgun
then they'd be the ones making the phone
call right so when you were saying um
some courts might not be responsive in
Florida or California that would be to
the F FBI's inquiry regarding the
original record it could also be to the
New Hampshire State Police okay yeah to
the Govern online yes okay correct all
right further questions
or representative
n um so I just want to um ask I know
that these were along the lines of the
the concerns that were raised by the
Coalition uh the domestic violence
Coalition and I'm just wondering since
this uh is dated today if the if they've
actually looked at the language
and yes I provided them with a copy as
well as the state police that were
represented here today and I wanted to
make sure that they had no more concerns
going forward on this okay thank
you okay see you no further the motion
is to adopt the amendment I would ask
cler to call the
role Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative pu yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative Gite yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolton yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Sunan yes representative
wheeler nay y yeah chairman
Roy cheer votes yay
190 19 190 the motion uh excuse me the
amendment 0 605h is officially adopted
uh will entertain an um a motion from
you representative stone I'd make a
motion ought to pass 1339 FN is there a
second to pass with amendment by the way
um seconded by representative approve of
the motion not to pass with Amendment
would you like to speak to your motion
real briefly Mr chair I'd like to just
reaffirm that this does not uh do
anything but add time frames for the
court to assess in the issue out a
hearing date the firearm background
checks are still would be completed as
required
previously would you like to speak to
your second representative Pro
negative um for discussion I just want
to for the record
clarify the only thing changed with
regard to returning Firearms to someone
who had a previous protection order
against them is that now there's a time
frame by which the court must issue an
order giving it back whereas before it
could take forever ever and they had to
go to court and request a motion to
return them is that correct that is
correct it sets a 10day window that they
have to hold a
hearing thank you further
discussion representative
Muse I would say what this bill does is
it points out the continued need for
people who are in domestic violence
situations and who have filed protective
orders if they feel that there are
circumstances that uh would lead them to
try to have those orders uh extended
those are things that they're going to
need to go to court to do uh and they're
going to need to show up to do that I I
don't think it's fair to um depend on an
inefficiency uh in in the system uh to
keep people away from uh uh even things
like Firearms um that are their property
um
unnecessarily so what this bill does um
as the chair said is it it adds uh some
more specific time frames FR it adds
some uh some guard rails around the set
of circumstances that where the guard
rails I think were a little bit
ambiguous before um so I'll support
it thank you for the
discussion seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendment I would ask
cler to call the role Vice chair roads
yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative pu
yes represent ative Janan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative G representative
representative Balden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Su Newman yes
representative wheer yay chairman Roy
chair votes yes
190 190 unanimous any objection to
consent seeing none it will go on
consent I hereby close the executive
session with that I open the executive
session
what which
one stand
by
yeah
all right with that I open the executive
session on House Bill
1658 and I recognize representative
rhods to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman um I move
itl for Hospital
1658 seconded by representative wheeler
would you like to speak to your motion
representative yes Mr chairman thank you
um I I understand the the genuine
concern that the sponsor and the
co-sponsor had um with bringing this
legislation forward but when we heard
the
testimony um it seems that this is could
cause a well actually will be a huge
Invasion to privacy um for for for any
patients and it seems to me that if
you you know there there are mechanisms
in place that if you have a loved one
that you know you need you feel that you
know has medical conditions that you
know these situations may arise you are
able to get guarded Guardianship and
when you have that guardianship then you
are able to put this out to the public
but to just to just say that somebody's
medical information should be shared
because you feel that their safety may
be in dang you really just can't do that
um and additionally we did pass a bill
last year that does allow you know
there's a a checkbox you know if there's
an elderly person that has you know
medical conditions maybe they have Al
Alzheimer's you know this may be
something that can be addressed in in
that way um but to just basically say
that you know a person's been in out of
the hospital and we want to share that
information with the public is is
something I just don't feel that is
right to do represent wheeler would you
like to speak to your second I think
RADS did it
perfectly I would um I would say this
that I think that the the um intent is
laudable um and I think that there may
be a way to do it and I think the
sponsor should not give up and and come
back with a better crafted bill that
includes input from all the stakeholders
then we might be able to do something
but uh it occurred to me you know if
that if there is such a database there
are departments in the state that don't
have mobile data Terminals and if they
need to query of dispatch regarding
something like this and they don't have
a secure Channel they're going to put
someone's medical information out over
scanner land where people in their homes
are going to sit there and listen to and
know all about the person's medical
history so it needs a lot of work um
with that further
discussion seeing none the Motions is
expedient legisl i' ask call the rooll
vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative pu yes representative
Janan yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative gather
representative Muse representative Balon
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman the clerk vot votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Sunan yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes
190 the motion of been expedient to
legislate carries by a vote of 19 to Zer
any objection to consent seeing none I
hereby close the public hearing I open
the public hearing on House Bill
1462 and recognize representative Murray
to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move in
terms study for House Bill 1462
is there a
second second representative Stone
representative Murray would you like to
speak to your motion yes I would thank
you Mr chair um during the hearing for
um a similar bill in the Senate um after
uh working on this bill initially with
the AG um we found out that the state
police is already collecting a lot of
this data and we need more time to
ensure that the bill is written in a way
that um does not conflict with the uh um
processes that are already in place um
so I would hope that the committee would
be um happy to continue work on that
language
um representative Stone would you like
to speak to you a second Mr chair I
would concur with representative Murray
and I think it's prudent to refer it to
a committee to do further
studying further
discussion seeing none the motion on the
floor is um interim study I would ask
clerk to call the role Vice chair roads
yes representative Pratt yes
representative scitec representative PR
yes representative
J Bradley representative Murphy yeah yes
representative Newman yes clerk votes
yes representative Newell yes
representative
Sunan yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair votes yes 190 the
vote of 19 to zero for um interim study
carries any objection to consent see
none goes on consent and close public
hearing with that I open the excuse me
the executive session with that I open
the executive session on House Bill 1701
um who would like to make that motion
representative n would you like to make
a motion uh yes I'd like to make a
motion to itm is there a second second
seconded by representative Murphy would
you like to speak to your motion
representative sure um the as written
this bill um had some serious flaws um
there was the timing was off it was
talking about uh from five years from
the date of commitment um rather than uh
the absolute discharge um there was also
Al unclear language in here who is a
medical professional there were a
variety of of um problems that U that
kind of sabotaged the intent of the bill
and I think the the comment was made uh
in this in this uh as we were talking
about it um for you know the authors of
the bill to bring forward an amendment
uh that might fix those problems and
they didn't do that
so
okay um would you like to speak to your
second representative Murphy yes thank
you um I some of the testimony we
received was that uh there was concern
that um if this information was annulled
it would not be available uh for those
Healthcare Providers um use in in
determining dangerousness Etc so um I uh
would support the um
I thank you um I would add that um
mental Health like any any um disease um
Can reoccur at any time sometimes years
later and someone may get better for a
while and without being able to look
back on the medical history which may
include a commitment um really
hamstrings a doctor's ability to further
treat that person um and the motivation
for that is um I I just don't understand
it so um with that being said
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chairman um I I think representative
Newell and yourself and representative
Murphy did a good job at explaining why
the itl on this bill is a is a good
thing the New Hampshire hospitals came
and testified about how it might
hamstring their ability
to bring consistency of care to a
patient who comes to the hospital and
and I think that's something that should
be that's a concern and I think as the
bill is written it would allow for
violent people to get some of their
rights back which is also a concern um
but I do just want to say for the sake
of Representative Reed who who brought
um really powerful testimony about uh
her story that of what she had gone
through um with domestic violence and
and with other things and and uh having
the process that she went through result
in her not being able to defend herself
I think is a concern and hopefully in
the next banum someone is able to bring
up legislation which addresses that and
make sure that people who are no longer
in danger to the themselves or others
are able to defend themselves in
whatever way they see fit as Ellen Reed
as representative Reed brought up here
to to the
committee I do not believe I was here
for that testimony um but it sounds like
it makes sense based on the short
recitation you said I would remind you
that um another bill that I and
representative Muse are bring in forward
allows people to have um their rights
restored who may have at one point um
not been able to have them which is
currently the State of Affairs in New
Hampshire further discussion represent
Muse I just wanted to add that this um I
think that this bill is is very well
intentioned but what it does is it
treads on the same ground as uh as HB
1711 and the ATF is very specific around
the types of uh programs that will
actually certify like this and I think
another thing from a mental health
perspective is um
what 1711 does is it is it looks at
unconditional discharge as being uh the
proper gate to look at in a situation
like this not just necessarily the
expiration of time because as
representative Roy said um mental health
can be an ongoing struggle that can last
for years and it was also pointed out to
us in committee that a person can
actually be involuntarily committed for
up to 5 Years in New Hampshire so if we
have a bill that says that um
essentially they can have their firearms
back uh at the end of 5 years you could
have a person conceivably walking out of
New Hampshire hospital one day uh and
buying Firearms the next so there are
there are issues uh with this particular
bill that I think are more effectively
dealt with in other legislation that's
before
us thank you um see you no further
discussion the motion on the floor is in
expedient to legislate I would ask the
clerk to call the
role Vice chair roads yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec yes
representative pu yes representative
janr yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative gri yes
representative
Muse yes representative Balden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes represent
ative Newell yes representative Su
Newman yes representative wheeler yay
chairman Roy chair yes 190 any objection
to consent seeing none the motion um
carries inexpedient to legislator go on
the consent calendar I close the
executive session House Bill
1701 and I believe we have one left and
we're still
waiting yeah we're going to take a a
1hour lunch break um I would suggest
that everyone use that time to get the
report T that have to be in today in
addition to getting yourself a sandwich
um and we will meet back here at uh
12:30
e
all
house pild
1701 and invite
the I'm sorry I don't even know where I
am um executive session
1337 and
recognizer my friend I'm going
home executive session House Bill 1330
and recognize representative approve to
make a
motion I make a motion to op to pass on
Amendment
2024 -
H is there a
second second by representative Stone
would you like to speak to your motion
yes I would so this amendment creates a
review panel for the Bureau of EMS in
the past it's been one
investigator
uh and not necessarily the same level
as the person being investigated so you
could have an EMT investigating a
paramedic and not knowing all the ins
and out of
paramedicine uh and I've have seen that
personally happen um so this creates a
three member board uh of the same level
or
higher to
uh take the information make a
determination in the past it has been uh
the investigator gave the information
to uh the commissioner of safety who is
a police
officer who has no EMS experience making
these decisions so I think in all
fairness the person making these
decisions should be their peers same
level or higher three of them looking at
uh the incident and coming up with a
determination it also states that that
if they cannot come up with a
determination in 90 days the panel has
to put in writing why it is going to be
longer than
that
and every 30 days after that with an
update um there have been uh cases where
it's been 11 plus months to get a
determination um and I find that a very
long time there was very communic little
communication back and forth on what was
going on and here you have this person
wondering whether they're going to be
able to take care of their family or
whatever is their license going to go
away is it not uh and I think that's a
very long time the other piece of this
is
um removes the web page that list
everybody that's um had a determination
or a finding
in public view
um this has been weaponized by uh some
of the members of where maybe this
person under investigation gets work is
working uh I've had personal um reports
to me firsthand that you know somebody
went under
investigation of not too serious an
incident with people saying hey I can't
wait to see your name up on the
website so I'd like that page taken down
the information will still be available
with a phone call an email or whatever
if they if someone is truly interested
in what's going on with that person if
they're going to hire them they want
their background they can still get it
um the other thing about that web page
is that they had people listed on there
that had passed
away and when the family members reached
out they were told yeah we can't take
the name down there's nothing in law
that allows us to to do that so that
person was going to live in infamy
forever even though they were dead and
there was no way they were coming back
to get a
job so that's pretty much what this does
I think is fixing uh some wrongs that
have been in the EMS system for a while
um I've heard numerous as I was looking
to do this numerous people who feel that
they really weren't treated very well
um and um the
process um was kind of rough so I I
would hope that members would vote with
me to uh fix this issue and if anybody
has any questions I'll try and answer
them for
him thank you representative Stone did
you want to speak to your a second thank
you Mr chair I would I think this
process outlays uh a little bit more due
process that's been afforded in the past
and I could see this as being a positive
moving forward
with professional
licensing thank you um I had a couple a
couple initial reactions first I I was a
little I questioned the part about
taking down the the information but now
that it's clear to me that the the
information is
not unavailable to to anyone to check
it's just not published and as this is
um these are people that work for
private companies at AMR ambulance or
something like that it it's I don't see
a public interest in putting people's
names it's not it's not like you can
pick your own EMT so you you know an
ambulance comes you can't go oh wait a
minute let me look check and see that
person's I mean they work there or they
don't it's up to the companies to decide
um and if it's open to companies to call
and get a list of people or check on
someone's history then it's fine with me
as long as it's available I don't see
the the interest in the public to
shaming people in regards to what
happened in their careers um also with
regard to the the panel I I feel like
it's you know when we look at medicine
the practice of medicine doctors have a
board they have a peer review board in
the hospital and when it comes to their
license they also have a Board of
Medicine that reviews What's Done um and
they're experts um they have the ability
to get experts to look at every case and
it's not never would they have for
example a an internist um or or someone
there you know brand new out a medical
school reviewing a surgeon for example
so it makes sense to me to have someone
of a higher or equal um background in
more than just one person making a
decision on someone's career so I I'm
going to I'm going to support this and I
would ask the members to consider that
and do so as well further discussion
represent
wheeler oh okay
representative um Harry gather um I
actually thought that this was a pretty
good bill initially um and what I did
like about it was the uh three member
disciplinary um review panel I thought
that was a great way instead of having
just one or two people making decisions
like
that but when I go to page
two
um Roman num 5
when it talks
about the 5 Years From the end of the ly
discipline that this be removed um I'm
really not for that I definitely believe
that this second piece of that where it
talks about the death of a person I am
very much for
that I don't believe that once someone
has left this Earth that you need to
continue um dispersing them for any
reason
so I'm going to say I'm not going to
vote for
this if I may representative Pro so that
piece was actually uh part of when the
web page was up that the names were
supposed to come off the web page and
and go into the file and still be
available in the
file uh there was an oversight on that
didn't coming out not coming out um
so I can make that come out that that
information is still available it's just
not published on a web
page representative
Murphy thank you Mr
chair um I know I've spoken with with
representative PR I I like most of this
bill I still have concerns about the
very last part um and I I hear his his
his the history that he has an
experience he had about a um this
information being weaponized and I I can
I can see how that can happen but I
think those people that are going to do
that no matter what whether there's a
website or there isn't a website um and
I I just I see it as a transparency
issue I think as a as a retired nurse I
know that if there were disciplinary
disciplinary actions taken um not during
the in investigation pH by what Upon A
determination that that information it's
sent out in um newsletters from the
board of registration and nursing that
information is on the board of
registration and Nursing website um so
that um even if um you're we don't pick
necessarily A a um uh an emergency
medical personnel if there is
information that is publicly available
on whether it's on certification or reg
a board
registration it may not make a
difference right away but if you're the
parent say of a child who goes in an
ambulance and there's a concern over
whatever treatment um and then you go to
look back about you know the care that
that your child may have received um I
do think that that information should be
available publicly um just as it is for
the board of Registration of Medicine or
the board of registration of Nursing or
Healthcare Providers um uh so that's I I
still have that problem the rest I agree
about the the five year the excuse me
about the um when a person is deceased
fully support that um I also support the
the um the disciplinary review panel I
think that's a really good idea too it's
just I'm I'm just concerned about um the
transparency issue and I and I I I don't
know it would be hard for me to support
it with that still in it thank you I
have a question
repr approv does the nursing board have
a website that
listed I don't know maybe yeah I don't
I've have not looked so that's I mean if
they have a website that list everybody
then I I get it but as far as I know the
EMS board is the only one that does
this I believe you can look up a doctor
I don't know about a nurse but there's
no website like with a list right there
you have to go in and click the doctor's
name so you know that whole weaponizing
thing they have a a a big TV screen and
up on it is the list when that person is
working because they said oh we're we're
waiting to see your name pop up so it's
not like they had to go look at at their
file send a email requesting it or such
but it's just this big thing that's
readily available
and Wheeler thank you Mr chairman I I
have a question for representative Pro
and you've kind of touched on this in
saying that
this saying that the finding or
determinations of such
investigations are not available via the
Internet or the website does not mean
that this information is not
available that is correct you call them
and say hey I want to find out about
Mark crew is he a good EMT does he have
any any bad spots on his record they
will tell you kind
um my next question would be how would
somebody go about getting that
information they would just contact the
director contact the bureau VMS say hey
we're looking to hire Mark crew um can I
get his record is there any uh findings
you know disciplinary findings in his
file and and that stuff so it's not a
ban on no allowing absolutely not
because I I don't want a bad EMT coming
to pick me up when I'm laying on the
ground looking up right yeah I want to
make sure everybody uh is doing what
they're supposed to and if they violated
uh their oath and and such I want people
to know about it but I just don't want
it out there weaponized yeah and I I
that's what I was my point when I said
about um public shaming it's different
if you want the information to make a
hiring determination or what have you
but it's different to just put someone's
name out there for no other reason than
to just say hey look at this person did
um that's what I was the point I was
making representative
Stone thank you Mr chair uh under
Section
Five does anything prohibit a uh
director from not removing it if uh they
deem it to be an issue such as maybe a
person shouldn't hold a license for the
rest of their uh
career so can he leave it up there
correct is that his at his discretion as
it stands right now they can't remove it
once it's on but your bill would allow
them to if they determine to remove it
right is that the way I'm reading it
correctly uh no shall so I imagine so if
you read it it's five years after their
um uh discipline is over so if they were
permanently
revoked there's no five years after that
they're revoked for their lifetime when
they when they pass then you could
remove them so follow up it that' be a
permanent record if they're revoked for
a lifetime Y
correct rep
Muse thank you I think one of the things
that we need to pay attention to in this
is I think there's a a difference
between intent which I think is good uh
and the actual language of the bill so
if you if you take a look page
two uh line nine it says the director
shall not publish or make public public
any ongoing investigations including the
findings or determinations of such
investigations uh via the Internet or
website so I think one of the things
that we need to be extremely careful
about
um is creating a situation where there
really would be any any less
transparency uh when it comes to these
investigations than uh than we have now
now um I think um the in you know saying
the internet or website it's extremely
broad what what do we mean you know
exactly uh you know by that um It just
strikes me that
the that um that the language that we're
using here is is is is overly broad um
and in the end may not actually
accomplish what the what the sponsors
looking to uh to accomplish without
creating some unintended
consequences
no yeah great second presed Murphy thank
you um I looked up the the um the
information that I would like to see
retained in these situations if a
determination has uh been made is
similar to the um New Hampshire office
of profession professional licensure and
certification looked at the board of
nursing and how we do it and the board
of nursing actions retains a
disciplinary documents on this website
for a 7-year period you can look it up
by by um year and um you know you can
verify lure so that's the part that I'm
looking to I think I agree with you I
just think that what this says is that
there's no documentation and it can be
just so if there's a way to say that
this information would be kept on
something like this I think that makes
sense um but I it's just right now it's
just too broad it's basic in the way I
read it it just says you that there's
going to be no um publishing of
determinations of Investigations on the
Internet or website so that would make
me think that it's meant to preclude
something like this and I don't think
that's what we want to
do it sounds like a represent Pro go
ahead so give you a history of my
background that is really kind of
driving this for me is that I run the
grand State critical instance stress
management team um that we assist police
Fire EMS and all emergency responders
including Hospital staff um get through
really bad calls and manage uh critical
stress that leads to Suicide right so my
number one goal right now is preventing
suicide and First Responders whatever
that takes and I try to remove move any
additional stress to them and to me
uh
this web page that is just their
disciplinary web page which I'm trying
to get to here in a
second and and
it's not listed by year it's just
listed everyone even if they're dead
um
so to relieve some of that
stress uh I think making it harder just
a little bit harder that it's not so
public and not so
easily accessed by people
who are just trying to weaponize it
right they're not they're not there
because they're going to hire that
person they're not there because they
have some issue that oh hey I was on
they came to my house and that guy with
a name tag I want to find out about him
sure they can call EMS and say hey what
about that EMT Mark Pro right what's the
deal with him does he have anything in
his background as opposed to this big
poster
that I don't
know may I um May I make a suggestion it
sounds like um everyone in here agrees
on a good portion of this bill but there
are some significant hurdles that are
going to keep a uh a majority to vote
out to pass I think that perhaps given
the time because we don't have really
the time to wait for another amendment
we vote um however that comes out and
then representative PR and maybe
representative Murphy could work
together because it's going to finance
and you can be amended again and finance
but if we we have to act on it today so
if if you could get agreement and get an
amendment in finance and then before it
comes to the floor with an OTP and
enough people will commit I think you
can pass this thing this year so what do
you I'm willing to work with anybody to
try and get to where we need to be
because I truly don't want to make it
impossible for people to find out about
bad EMTs because I don't want that
either yeah I think if you look at the
language they're going to come get me
right if you look at the language
whatever the law is that allows the
nursing to do that it might already be
there and you just take it and copy it
and so so I'll reach out to uh um
because let's get it out of here Senate
the finance you continue to work see if
um whoever what division gets it and
they might entertain your Amendment
representative
Newman I just want to this process we
you would prefer we vote it in this
condition than it is and then if we if
if it gets to finance and finance
doesn't an amendment or they don't agree
with the amendment that they put out
then it gets passed the way it is no no
I'm not asking you to vote you vote
however you want here no I I know I
understand I'm just I'm I'm asking the
process that's that's let's say that
process let's say we vote 1010 or
whatever we have here today and it goes
to finance and finance tells him nah get
out of here with your Amendment he can
then go with the floor Amendment um or
they could say no the money's not there
I mean there's a lot of different scenar
iOS but in order to to get the support
of members in this committee at least
that have said they would support it if
it was changed I would recommend that he
do that and there's an opportunity of
Finance I would do it here but we're out
of time um because of the
deadline so vote how you're going to
vote it's going to finance
regardless um even if it comes out of
here itl is still going to finance so
there's another bite at that apple
representative
Pratt I might assume that in finance
they would address the inflation of the
cost of this bill would be the prime
reason that they would deal with it yeah
there is an inflation
here
site although Finance is going to look
at the money I think you've said
something important which is that this
committee would send a a wink in effect
that we're willing to uh modify
fine-tune the language to uh reflect
what pretty much is the consensus of the
good intentions of the bill something
that's not been talked about and I I
would I couldn't vote for this without
that understanding is this
whole uh I guess it's my Edna experience
but the pool of applicants is um uh
appointed by one person
is he is there a term is it an ad hoc
committee is it uh uh can he be serves
at the pleasure uh that that whole thing
that disciplinary re review panel needs
to be firmed up specified something but
right now uh there he can appoint a 100
people there's no limit there's
no it is not defined and that needs to
for my vote that needs to be uh good
intention or not that needs to be uh
adjusted
or uh
made made definite uh as to how it
operates how it's appointed uh whatever
it's ter I I I'm repeating
myself yeah I thought it was in
there I would suggest you look at it um
based on based on that
um since we do have to move this out of
here today um I think we've had enough
discussion what we'll do is we'll vote
and then it goes to finance I would um
I'll send a note to finance and say that
there were a couple policy issues that
we ran at a time that we'd like to see
and I would appreciate if they would
entertain an amendment that was brought
by representative PR um and if um if
they will that's good and if not he'll
have to do it on the
floor but um it sounds like if he fix
those couple things he'd at least have
the support of the entire committee so
representative wheeler just really
quickly Mr chairman thank you I just
have a process question I'm wondering
instead of having this motion go to itl
would it be possible to bring this
motion to the floor with an interim
study reverse that motion and then amend
it from there rather than it go to the
floor with an ideal motion I don't know
that it would go to finance with an
interm study so it we that might happen
and then we would reverse it and then it
would go back to finance again um or it
would be recommitted I mean we can make
a motion Go finance immediately after
our committee it goes to the floor no
that's what that's yeah yeah yeah so
yeah I'm not sure what the best way to
do that would be representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman uh knowing that
there' be bipartisan support from
representative PR and Murphy I'd be okay
with voting a to pass at this time and I
support
that representative Murray thank you Mr
chair I was going to suggest maybe if
representative PR and Murphy work on an
amendment before this goes to the floor
and then we can just pass as a floor
Amendment and then we send it to finance
all set that said that that made much
more sense than everything I said um if
if representative Murphy and PR work on
it and it's going to come to the floor
you bring it as a floor Amendment and
then it will go to finance as an ought
to pass with the policy part taken out
right and then they can just deal with
the money
um
mention yeah the vote is what it is
today and then we can uh its
representative proves uh ball to win
over the rest of the members on the
floor yeah so right now currently before
us is the adoption of the amendment so
we have to uh take that up first so I'd
ask the clerk to call the role in the
amendment um the motion is adopt
Vice chair RS yes representative Pratt
yes representative
scitec representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
gther yes representative muse no
representative
Balden no representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy
no representative Newman
no the clerk votes yes representative
new yes representative Su Newman no
representative
wheeler
yay chairman
Roy see votes
yes
like I said right in
the it's um
145 okay the the U amendment is adopted
by vote of 14 to5 at this point we will
um I need another motion represent per
representative approve would you like to
make a motion of to passing amended yes
I would love to make a motion of ought
to pass with Amendment second seconded
by representative Stone would you like
to speak to your
motion
19 close sorry I was trying to work on
our
Amendment so I think I've talked enough
of this uh we have a good plan to make
the final Amendment on that one little
piece we're looking to follow the OPC um
method so I think if we can do that
we'll all be
fine representative Stone did okay and
further discussion representative
Jam yes Mr chairman uh I would recommend
that the report that's filed on behalf
of the committee actually say that you
guys are working on a floor amendment to
be introduced on the floor so that give
everybody a heads up thank you okay
um who's G to once we vote who's going
to write
[Music]
to that's the the pass so
the okay
majority
all right with that I'd ask the clerk to
call the role motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate oh excuse me
representative sitech ought to pass yeah
that too ought to
pass all right representative scitec
weighs off motion on floor is ought to
pass with Amendment Vice chair rhs yes
representative Pratt yes representative
citec representative PR yes
representative janen yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes Representative
gther no representative muse no
Representative bden no representative
Bradley no representative Murphy no
representative Newman no the clerk votes
no representative Newell no
representative Su Newman no
representative wheeler next chairman
Roy chair votes no um 8 to
11 motion fails
okay new
motion I'll move uh inexpedient to
legislate second second representative
gather I think we've discussed it so
representative um unless anyone else has
something to say uh that's
representative Muse I would just like to
call your attention to the fact that
from a process standpoint one of the
things that is an option uh is uh all of
our recommendations can be approved or
defeated on the house floor um if the
itail motion is defeated on the floor
then a new Amendment uh a floor
amendment can still be brought to the
floor so I would urge representative
Murphy um and representative PR to
continue working on the on that floor
Amendment and we did this just last week
so this is this is not a not a shot in
the dark this is something that we can
do
on I think that's what we said we were
doing right exactly yeah okay um so um I
moved to itl who seconded
that Linda all right we discussed it
enough please call the
RO Vice chair
roads yes representative Pratt no
representative
scitec representative PR no
Representative janen no representative
Manion no representative Reed no
representative Stone no repr
representative tar or sorry
representative G
yes representative
Muse yes representative Balden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes uh the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Sunan yes representative wheeler nay
chairman
Roy chair votes yes motion
is 12 to7 motion of inexpedient to
legislate 12 to 7 carries I will be
writing the uh majority
report and who will be represent for are
you going to
write I guess so um mine's pretty much
going to say look at look under your
seat yeah that's what I'm going to say
this floor okay thank
you yeah yeah okay well look under there
anyway because you should know what's
under your seat mine's under my seat
because I sit dead ass in the middle of
section
three one one other suggestion is that
floor amendment should it come um if it
it would be a great idea to get it to
the members of the committee well in
advance or whatever the house session is
so we can take a look at it and have a
chance to discuss it and if it looks
good then we can reverse this
thing all right everyone um enjoy the
rest of your week we're actually not
here again till the 21st what oh my
goodness
your
mom's happy 31st
Linda go ahead Jonah throw a grenade and
leave get out of here get into the
airport we do not again everyone 21st we
will be back again so that's next
Wednesday and I've scheduled next
Thursday in case there's no house
session so let's
see